die Welt ist die Bild-Zeitung für
Architekten und Rechtsanwälte und
mit dabei natürlich bei dem Bashing
immer die CSU der Empfänger für das
gesunde Volksempfinden vorneweg
Alexander Dobrindt er hat ja
an uns alle appelliert in diesem
Jahr eine Klima RAF zu verhindern
bis zum Ende studiert hast einen Abschluss und bis
die Blumen Soziologe davon merkt man zwar meistens
nichts aber egal aber du müsstest doch mit einem
minimalen Grundwissen wissen wer die RAF war die
RAF hat über 30 Menschen brutal ermordet war eine
Terrororganisation im Untergrund und wollte den
Staat das schweine-system Zerstören die letzte
Generation ist im übergrund und fordert den Staat
auf endlich zu handeln Wille 9 euro-ticket und
Tempo 100 auf Autobahn merkst du da vielleicht
ein klitzekleiden Unterschied aber gut selbst
von einem diplomierten Soziologen muss man ja
nicht unbedingt Geschichtsbewusstsein
erwarten hat Dobrind doch schon vor ein
paar Jahren eingefordert es sei höchste
Zeit für eine konservative Revolution
das letzte Mal als sowas gefordert wurde das
war in der Weimarer Republik und es hat den
Nazis den Weg an die Macht geebnet konservative
Revolution sowas hatten in diesem Jahr ja auch
die Reichsbürger vor na vielleicht hätte
der Dobrind damals ein Auge drauf werfen
soll hat mir von ihm aber irgendwie nichts
gehört haben einige nur Verharmlosung was
waren die da so eine Welle paar Rollatoren
Revoluzzer die Kukident Nazis oh ja Prinz
Heinrich der Viertel vor zwölfte so lächerlich
gut hey aktive Richterin war auch noch dabei
die für die AFD im Bundestag gehabt hat ja
ein paar Bundeswehrsoldaten jüngere auch
ja zwei drei von den KSK Spezialkräften
ja Beamter vom LKH Niedersachsen Bereich
staatsschutzärztin aber sonst genau
guck mal der bürgerbräuboutsch was
der Hitler vorgehabt hat mit
seiner Frau nazi-spinnen 1923
geworden ne also zumindest in dem Jahre nicht nein
nein die waren Gefährder bei uns das sind Fridays
for future und die letzte Generation was dafür
eine Aggression geschürt wird gegen die Jugend
die schulschwänze die schulschwänze die klebe die
sollen sich mal politisch engagieren statt sich
dauernd nicht nur wo sie keine brauchen die sollen
sich einbringen das würden einige junge einige
sehr junge sehr gerne machen mitmischen geht noch
nicht so ganz weil Wahlrecht erst ab 18 und das
will die Ampel ja ändern der Jugend mehr Gewicht
geben dass die Alters Pyramide mal ein bisschen zu
Recht gewunkelt wird und wildes Wahlalter im Bund
auf 16 Jahre heruntersetzen wer eigentlich auch
logisch ne sie dürfen in manchen Bundesländern
wählen sie dürfen bei den Europawahlen wählen
warum dürfen sie eigentlich nicht im Bund wählen
weil es dafür eine Grundgesetzänderung braucht
dafür braucht es eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit und
die wird aber nicht geben weil ein monolithischer
Block dagegen steht die alten weißen Frauen
und Männer von Union und AFD die Koalition der
Freiwilligen die unisono betont das geht nicht
mit 16 ist man noch zu leicht manipulierbar
was ein Glück dass das im
hohen Alter nachlässt und
aber
aber die Union ist wieder
kompromissbereit arbeitet
schon an einem Gegenentwurf Wahlrecht erst ab 65
es sind doch so ihre Zeiten da ist doch mal ein
neues Denken gefragt und es kann doch so schwer
nicht sein weil angeblich leben wir schon seit
Ende Februar in der viel beschworenen zeitenwände
aber allmählich fragt sie endlich und kommst in
die Zeit von von wendet sich endlich die Zeit was
haben sie den Kanzler gelobt nach seiner großen
Rede nahm sein im Bundestag Olaf der starke klingt
nach so einem großen Wikinger ne oder danach kam
er doch wieder rüber wie der kleine Wiki ich meine
ich verstehe es er hat's nicht leicht mit seiner
Ampel na immer wenn er mal gedacht hat also jetzt
ist mal ein bisschen Ruhe kam zuverlässig immer
einer um die Ecke gegrätscht Christian Lindner
der eigentliche Oppositionsführer im Parlament
blöd nur dass er immer noch nicht
gemerkt hat dass er nicht mehr in der
Opposition sondern in der Regierung sitzt
nee das erste Jahr mit der Ampel hat
gezeigt man kann nur dann so richtig schlecht
regieren wenn die FDP mit im Boot sitzt dabei
man muss der Ampel auch schon mal zu Gute halten
sie hat der auch von Anfang an wirklich viel zu
tun na guck mal also erstmal 16 Jahre her blast
muss mir erstmal abgearbeitet werden eine 16 Jahre
an denen eine Partei nie beteiligt war die jetzt
aber für alles verantwortlich gemacht werden die
Grünen Waschlappen Kretschmann hat es glasklar
erkannt wir müssen jetzt all das aufwischen
was die anderen all die Jahre zu deppert haben wir
sind da wie schmeckt der Ampel wir sind im Eimer
Corona
corona-krieg Energiekrise Inflation noch nie
zuvor war eine Regierung von Beginn an mit einem
solchen Berg an Herausforderungen konfrontiert
und musste so viele ihrer Prinzipien über Bord
werfen mal ganz ehrlich wenn ich letztes Jahr im
Spätsommer wenn ich da gesagt hätte pass mal auf
nach der Bundestagswahl wird die SPD stärkste
Partei und stellt den Kanzler der als erstes
mit seiner Friedenspartei 100 Milliarden Paket
für die Bundeswehr Schnüren muss und Waffen in
ein Kriegsgebiet liefert während die Grünen
im Nahen Osten um fossile Brennstoffe betteln
Kohlekraftwerke neu anfeuern und auf Ostermärschen
nicht mehr versonnen singen kumbaya sondern
kämpferisch die Banner hochhalten Frieden schaffen
mit immer schwereren Waffen bevor die FDP um die
Ecke bieten wir machen Schulden wie noch nie da
werden die Männer mit der weißen Jacke gekommen
und hätten mich abgeholt ich wäre heute noch
nicht da diese krisenregierung mal ganz ehrlich
Friedrich Merz der schneidige haut drauf der
stellt doch jeden Abend der Kerze ins Fenster
und schlägt drei Kreuze wie gut dass ich all das
ganz bequem von der Oppositionsbank aus ansehen
kann und nicht in Verantwortung beweisen muss
was ich alles nicht kann Friedrich Merz [Applaus]